[Música]
escala en París Ahí va para la
Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
en los próximos días Francia se mueve a
ritmo del continente latinoamericano Y
es que hasta el 10 de junio se celebran
las semanas de América Latina y el
Caribe llegamos a la décima edición de
esta iniciativa que se creó en 2011 y
que programa actividades en todos los
campos que contribuyan a las relaciones
que unen el continente latinoamericano
con Francia y en esta ocasión hemos
querido hablarles de una revista que
ilustra a la perfección estos vínculos
el ojo vulgar o ya hacen escala en París
dos de sus artífices Natalia Vélez
Muchísimas gracias muchas gracias Aida
por la invitación y Alexander Ortega
bienvenido gracias por la invitación
Bueno vamos a empezar con Natalia
Natalia Vélez psicoanalista ha publicado
varios relatos poemas y ensayos es
fundadora del colectivo el círculo y la
directora de esta revista de arte y
cultura el ojo vulgar Cómo nace la idea
y por qué Este título tan tan sugerente
bueno
ojo vulgares además de una revista es
una plataforma de intercambio cultural
como bien Lo estabas mencionando ahora
con relación a esto de la semana el
intercambio el marco de la semana de
América Latina acá en Francia
precisamente nosotros buscamos hacer un
puente No pero no un puente solamente de
Unión sino ver toda la influencia que ha
podido tener la cultura y el arte
latinoamericano en Europa que es menos
de pronto dicho y también evidentemente
ya lo sabemos el europeo en
Latinoamérica entonces hemos querido
poder visibilizar a través de un
recorrido en los las vanguardias de arte
y cultura más representativas con sus
exponentes artistas
Editores personalidades importantes para
que hagan de telón para pasar no a
visibilizar a los nuevos artistas al
nuevo arte a los invisibles y los nuevos
códigos que se están gestando alrededor
de estos universos una revista también
como como trampolín para para los nuevos
Alexander Ortega usted Es doctor en
estudios hispánicos y escritor ha
publicado en varios medios como el
periódico El Tiempo de Colombia y dirige
la sección Lázaro arte y cultura en esta
revista en ojo vulgar explíquenos Cómo
aterriza en este proyecto Y por qué
Lázaro arte y cultura Bueno muchísimas
gracias por esta invitación Bueno este
proyecto es proyecto de amistad hace por
un grupo de amigos hace casi 10 años en
esas conversaciones que se inician en
Precisamente en los cafés en París y
tuve la gran oportunidad de conocer a
Natalia y conocer a su a su hermana
Juliana Vélez y después al otro a parte
del equipo a Sebastián y María Fernández
y nace precisamente de la idea de querer
Mostrar o actualizar el mito de París
pero desde nuestra desde nuestra
experiencia y creo que pasamos por
diferentes tipos de proyectos pero
gracias a Natalia y a Juliana y a
Sebastián y a María Fernanda el proyecto
comienza a tener forma y yo participo en
la parte de Lázaro arte y cultura que es
esta referencia precisamente como ha
resucitar ya a darle un nuevo espacio a
qué están haciendo los latinoamericanos
en París esta gente invisible esta gente
que está haciendo poesía esta gente que
está haciendo teatro que son muchísimos
no porque bien sabemos que son
precisamente los latinoamericanos que
siguen
creando el mito de París sobre el arte y
la cultura entonces por eso se llama
Lázaro arte y cultura es la referencia
bíblica no me ha dicho por qué ojo
vulgar Ah Es verdad es cierto ojo vulgar
de hecho como su nombre lo indica y su
eslogan que es tan fisgón tan Busca un
poco dar esa visibilidad no ser fisgón
En el sentido que hablaba Alexander
ahora
y bueno y tiene digamos todo una un
enganche en los surrealista un enganche
en jugar un poco con la poesía casi
diría yo surrealista de de Bueno es un
ojo que puede ser algo muy bonito que
puede ser algo
que impacta de muchas maneras pero es
vulgar es decir
expone no no solo por exponer sino por
crear al mismo tiempo por por Mostrar
otro lado no otra visibilizar el racismo
tiene mucha importancia de hecho es muy
surrealista ahora que hablaba de del
surrealismo que ha acogida está teniendo
porque tiene mucho mérito no hacer una
revista en papel en Francia en español y
en francés en la época digital donde los
jóvenes no aguantan ni medio párrafo no
leyendo en efecto en efecto esa es una
de las preguntas que además nos han
hecho muchos de nuestros amigos
franceses y demás nos decían Pero por
qué volvieron a al papel no y decíamos
el papel Más allá de ser un medio muy
poético no y
de antaño y de vanguardia pienso que
logra crear en este momento con ojo
vulgar una contracultura nuevamente es
decir en el mundo digital volvamos al
papel la alternativo es el papel Por
supuesto y también volver a esta calidad
artística no que puede representar el
papel para todos nosotros los artistas y
los escritores en este último número
raros Bueno siempre hablan de cine y
arte y literatura no en todos los
números en este tercero
hablan de bergman Por qué bergman Y
nosotros en este número que está
centrado en tema de identidades claro
bueno nosotros tenemos una unión entre
cine y literatura cine y otras artes
visuales como fotografía poesía como
decía Alex y bueno
parte del cine Cuando hablamos de
identidad nos basamos en una serie de
de obra cinematográficas bergman nos
interesó porque en bergman está persona
no una de las grandes obras de este
maestro del cine y persona es una es una
película que si bien habla de la
identidad habla de la identidad amplia
abierta general no es una identidad
específica hacia lo sexual hacia lo de
género hacia de pronto lo social sino es
algo más
fantasmagórico un poco más del
imaginario y de los representantes
generales de lo que es la identidad en
el hombre en el ser humano no en este
número ocupa un lugar especial especial
Alexander Ortega que es además el autor
de la noche de los hombres espejos y se
puede leer un extracto de este libro en
esta revista Alexander que se interesa
mucho en el tema de las identidades
sexuales y de género pero no solo Porque
tanto interés en este aspecto
bueno parte bueno la reflexión parte
precisamente del entorno en que en que
en que vivo o sea Y muchísimas historias
que he escuchado bueno Soy gay y hace
parte también de algunas preguntas como
latinoamericanos de estar viviendo en
París y en esta Crónica exploró la el
punto de vista de un periodista que no
tiene de pronto basándome un poquito de
capuchinski que es este periodista de
guerra que se va a una fiesta y le hace
la entrevista a un score Qué puede
decirnos un score sobre la identidad y
sobre la sexualidad Entonces es a través
de un es un recorrido por diferentes
imaginarios o los clichés del mundo gay
no pero qué hay detrás del fiché Cuáles
son esas grandes verdades y creo que esa
Esa fue el interés de la noche de los
hombres espejo justamente en el marco de
las semanas de América Latina Latina y
el Caribe en Francia organizan un
diálogo en torno a este tema
identidades y diversidad en el instituto
Cervantes de París no tienen la
impresión que a veces estamos
reivindicando nuestras identidades
sexuales estamos dando como demasiada
importancia es decir ya no nos definimos
como clase trabajadora sino venga
primero yo soy gay yo soy trans yo soy
Bibi yo soy Tri no sé o sea en este
debate no piensan que estamos eso
primero diciendo Bueno pues yo soy
bisexual Pero bueno Luego también soy
artista o me gusta el cine o yo que sé o
soy enfermero no sé qué opinan Por
supuesto me parece que es muy
interesante eso que estás diciendo
porque y precisamente es uno de los
anclajes principales de raros no y de La
Crónica de la noche de los hombres
espejo porque si bien evidentemente
ahora tenemos un auge en todo lo que es
identidad sexual e identidad de género
nos parecía que era importante rescatar
la diversidad en general es decir
tenemos que poder apoyarnos en el hecho
de que es tan importante
como
como no al mismo tiempo digámoslo así
porque es tan importante tener una
identidad
fija en algo es decir un anclaje una
posición en el mundo frente al otro no
como también saber que eso cambia todo
el tiempo que tiene una mutación no
entonces creo que así como uno puede ser
artista y también puede ser escritor
digo artista plástico y también escritor
uno puede ser no sé en algún momento de
su vida de un género o de una sexualidad
Y reconvertirse de pronto mutar hacia
otros
otros posicionamientos subjetivos porque
en el 2023 no se obsesiona tanto la
identidad o no es algo exclusivo de
ahora yo pienso que la identidad siempre
ha obsesionado a la humanidad no O sea
saber quiénes somos en el mundo y
y yo creo que los artistas la literatura
ha sido una literatura contada bueno
inicialmente por hombres eh Bueno le nos
han hecho creer que ha sido siempre
contaba por hombres y yo creo que las
preguntas que uno comienza a hacer una
revisión del de Quienes cuentan la
historia hay preguntas que atraviesan lo
humano no entonces creo que lo la
identidad es hablar sobre el Humano
cuando yo hice esta Crónica no no
pretendo y no ninguna reivindicación
política eran preguntas como
latinoamericanos que me hago en París no
Qué significa
el encuentro con otro hombre no Qué
significa el mundo los afectos No
únicamente la sexualidad Entonces sí es
verdad que históricamente se podría
hacer una una línea de Por qué la
identidad está tomando tanta fuerza
Comenzando por los movimientos civiles
la reivindicación de los grupos
afrodescendientes pero da la casualidad
que estoy en París y quise escribir una
crónica bueno fue primero que todo una
inquietud
escritural porque me gusta mucho
Emmanuel carrera y me gusta mucho
capuchinski y dije Bueno Cuál es el tema
que más conozco los hombres y lancé una
por eso es una una misana saber cómo
cuento la historia contando cosas que
mis amigos me habían dicho cosas que he
escuchado que y que uno Lee Y tratar de
actualizar esos imaginarios en este
momento preciso entonces entra dentro de
la identidad en un género como el de la
de La Crónica No claro yo quería
simplemente decir que
está esto de la identidad está muy
vinculado a lo que oíamos anteriormente
ahí situada de la enfermedad mortal no
en la desesperación es la enfermedad
mortal Y de alguna manera creo que la
identidad siempre ha sido como decía
Alex muy bien
una obsesión una obsesión en el hombre
de poder de saber quién es pero a la vez
de no ser de pronto no querer ser Quién
es O sea hay toda una una cuestión de sí
de fluidez en esto de la identidad que
angustia mucho no Y eso cobra otra
dimensión cuando uno vive en una ciudad
que nos la suya en un país que no es el
suyo que se agrega esa dimensión de del
extranjero No ya nos queda muy poquito
tiempo hay muchos temas que se nos han
quedado en el tintero Espero que podamos
en otras ocasiones solo decir que ya
están preparando el próximo número que
el tema va a ser muy apasionante la
novela policial el crimen perfecto de
forma muy muy breve Natalia que nos
puede adelantar en 20 segundos Claro
pues
se va a basar en en esto en la novela
policíaca en todo lo que es un poco cine
negro empieza el Thriller psicológico y
podemos decirles que va a estar muy
bueno porque vamos a tener entrevistas y
textos inéditos de autores
latinoamericanos y europeos muy
importantes Bueno pues muchísimas
gracias Natalia Vélez y Alexander Ortega
por haber estado con nosotros y Les
deseamos muchísimos éxitos con el ojo
vulgar y gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir también en internet en rf
y mundo.com y en France 24.com Hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]